hi I'm Jon Favreau here for Fandango
movie clips here are things to know
before you go to see Jungle Book one of
my goals here was to combine what I
remembered from the animated classic
with a newer version of the film that
took full advantage of the digital
environment that we were creating the
challenge was how do you take a g-rated
musical and transpose it to a PG rated
film that had a sense of adventure for
all ages the big effort was to combine
the images the music the moments that I
remembered and loved with something new
and completely surprising there are a
lot of moments I wanted to include based
on my memory of the film that I grew up
watching Balu floating down the river
with Mowgli singing bare necessities of
kava the snake wrapping himself in coils
around Mowgli as he hypnotized the kid
preparing to eat him I remember the
elephant's marching Mowgli having a
moment with the baby elephant I remember
the temple collapsing the monkeys
kidnapping Mowgli and carrying him off
to King Louie and I remember she akan
stalking through the grass and trying to
hunt down Mowgli who was unaware that he
was being hunted by this predator we use
a combination of technologies to tell
the story we use part of the animation
process to discover the story and the
visuals we use motion capture that was
innovated on films like Avatar to help
figure out the choreography and and
where the cameras would be and finally
we shot Neel Sethi as Mowgli in very
limited sets and jungle environments to
be an element within this completely
digital world that we would create
populated by digital animated animals
because we had one young actor playing
Mowgli and other humans on the set we
ended up having Jim Henson's company
design and perform with puppets to keep
Neel Sethi completely engaged I do a
voice a few voices actually in the movie
I do play the pygmy hog I also did a lot
of acting that you'll never see because
it was replaced by digital performances
but when you're seeing Neel Sethi as
Mowgli singing bare necessities with
Baloo I was actually in the tank with
him singing with him and splashing him
with water Neel Sethi
came with me to visit Bill Murray for
his first recording session of course
bill being
very gregarious character really sparked
off well with with Neil they played some
football outside while I cooked for
everybody and it was a real wonderful
way for us all to meet each other thanks
for watching Fandango movie clips things
to know before you go to see Disney's
The Jungle Book coming to theaters April
15